je vais vous emmener euh dans une autre
France la France
ultramarine donc je ne sais pas si vous
connaissez la Guyane si vous la
connaissez pas je vous invite à nous
rendre visite pour toucher les réalités
de ce territoire alors pour relier
Cayenne en partant de la commune
amérindienne Camopi c'est vrai qu'il
aurait fallu avoir la carte mais je
pense que par les mots vous allez
comprendre il faut pas moins de 48
heures de trajet ces conditions rendent
très compliquée l'intervention de la
déléguée régionale au droits des femmes
et récemment d'ailleurs elle
m'expliquait que qu'il lui était
impossible d'organiser la prise en
charge des femmes victimes de violence
dans cette commune enclavée de Guyane
madame la ministre que pouvons-nous
faire pour éviter la double peine à ces
femmes victime à la fois de
l'éloignement et des coûts des hommes la
guuane également est très confronté au
phénomène des grossesses précoces ou non
désiré en cause la sous-utilisation des
moyens de contraception le ministère que
vous avez en charge annoncer il y a
quelques mois une mobilisation en faveur
de l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes dans les territoires ultramarins
il a été notamment question de l'accès
des femmes à la santé et de l'adaptation
des campagnes de prévention et
sensibilisation pourtant une responsable
du réseau périnat guyan indiquait il y a
peu qu'il subsiste des obstacles pour
accéder à la contraception que
comptez-vous faire pour faciliter
l'accès à la contraception en guyan vous
relevez une réalité terrain que je ne
suis pas venu voir de mes yeux mais que
je je connais je sais qu'il y a il y a
il y a beaucoup de sujets et beaucoup de
difficultés notamment en Guyane et vous
l'avez d'ailleurs dit avec notamment les
temps de trajet qui font que c'est très
difficile pour les jeunes filles d'avoir
accès un certain nombre de choses don
déjà dire que on agit notamment sur la
sur le sujet de la contraception d'abord
parce que il y a un appel à projet de
500000 € qui a été lancé en juillet 2023
pour soutenir notamment les les projets
qui prévoit de renforcer des actions en
matière de santé dans les
outres-mers ça vise notamment à
améliorer l'accès à la contraception
également des actions des des également
des des des difficultés en couche que
peuvent rencontrer les les femmes et
puis également sur la santé prénatale
des des des
enfants donc cette commission nationale
elle a retenu 38 projets à mi-novembre
dont sont situés en Guyane notamment
comme le projet oyapoc coopération
santé il y a également donc l'accès au
préservatifs masculins qui sont
remboursés donc pour tous donc ça c'est
important il faut aussi le faire
connaître dans le département de la
Guyane parce que c'est absolument
important que les que les les les jeunes
et moins jeunes se protègent lors de
leur relations sexuelles deème question
en 2021 il y a trois des cinq
départements et régions d'outrem qui
figurent parmi les 10 départements avec
les taux de violence conjugale les plus
élevés euh donc c'est la Guyane la
Guadeloupe et la Réunion et la guyen a
le taux de féminicide le plus important
en 2021 avec un taux supérieur de
1%000 donc on met en place des
dispositif il y a l'appel à projet qui a
été lancé conjointement avec le mefh et
le myum structuré autour trois axes déjà
l'adaptation des des campagnes de
prévention et de sensibilisation et
d'information aux spécificités du
territoire notamment l'utilisation de la
traduction et le doublage en langue
locale donc pour ce sujet il y a 38
projets retenus dont se en Guyane pour
un montant de 94000
€. il y a également des permanences
juridiques de proximité qui peuvent
aider les femmes qui sont
particulièrement victimes de violence
intrafamilial qui a un gros sujet dans
les départements d'outremer c'est aussi
le fait que les gens connaissent tout le
monde et ça pour quand on parle de de
l'éviction du du du domicile de partir
précipitamment et de se cacher de son
conjoint violent on se cacheou alors en
guyan peut-être un peu plus qu'ailleurs
mais sur l'île de la
Guadeloupe c'est plus compliqué voilà
doncf on est bien conscient en fait de
de de cette de cette difficulté